all right joining us now we have a lot
of news to get to tonight the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Devin
Nunez mr. chairman good to see you
the first thing I want is your reaction
to rod Rosenstein it's a two-part
question did he threaten to subpoena the
emails of you other members of Congress
your staffs and other documents because
he had one of his temper tantrums and
got angry well Sean it's great to see
you live in Singapore I think you should
come home eventually but I enjoy seeing
you there listen this is been going on
for since last August we subpoenaed then
last August as you know you've covered
it every night on your show we continue
to try to get documents we can't get
documents we've had many what I would
say altercations with the Deputy
Attorney General and his staff what I
think is inappropriate I'm fine I can
take the heat you can attack me all you
want I'm used to it I enjoy it however
when it comes to attacking staff and
when staff feel uncomfortable that's
when you've gone too far these are the
staff our citizens the United States who
work hard for their country they're
Patriots they don't have the ability to
come on television like I do and plead
my case so look the staff definitely
have felt threatened just recently the
staff were all kicked out of the room
what people should be concerned about
the most right now
there's obstruction of a valid
congressional investigation by the
Department of Justice and let me explain
to you just one point and I'll go back
to you Sean just one simple point we've
been investigating this for a year and a
half
FISA abuse and other matters we now are
at the end we need documents that to
actually get to the bottom of what
actually happened in this situation they
now just in the last weeks have kicked
out the staff the lead investigators on
this now they've kicked out all of the
House Intelligence Committee members so
the only ones are going to provide
documents to in the whole entire House
of Representatives only two Republicans
Paul Ryan the speaker and myself this is
totally unacceptable it is a classic
case of obstruction of a congressional
investigation
the problem we have here is who's going
to investigate the investigators let me
ask you about one particular staffer by
the name of Kash Patel is he the one or
one of the people that got kicked out of
the room congressman and I really want
to know when you threaten and intimidate
to use the power of that office of being
the Deputy Attorney General isn't that
itself a form of obstruction and does
that raise the question of impeaching
rod Rosen Stein well I will tell you I'd
rather not get into the names of the
staff okay we have it and it's more than
one for the particular incident there
were three staff in the room but there's
been many other staff I think that have
felt threatened at different levels by
the Department of Justice and look they
have not been intimidated okay and our
members have not been intimidated but
what they've done now you know how do
you get to obstruction how do you get to
misleading Congress by taking this
information that we've been legally
asking for a legal subpoena that we're
trying to enforce and you now move it
upstairs and you say oh no no this is
now going to be super top secret
information that were only going to give
to the gang of eight hey that's what's
happening here that people in America
should be alarmed this is a way to hide
information not only from the American
people but to their congressman and to
the staff across from congressman how do
you possibly get it and is it true that
rod Rosenstein blew up at you a number
of times and that he has a horrible
temper and do you view his threat as a
form of obstruction in and of itself
that's an important question whether or
not he should remain in that role well
let me answer the first part but first
of all I can't do psychoanalysis on on
rod Rosenstein what I can tell you is is
that the behavior is is unacceptable his
unwillingness to provide documents I
said this a couple weeks ago on Maria's
Sunday morning show on Fox
I said look all you have to do if you
didn't if there's no FISA abuse here if
there are no problems with the FISA
application if there were no problems if
informants or spies or whatever we're
running to the Trump campaign all you
have to do
is show the House Intelligence Committee
all of the documents let the
investigators comb through the documents
and look we're not getting that so what
does what does that tell it what does
that tell you we would exonerate them in
a second so you know where does this
leave from here tomorrow we have this IG
report coming out I think this is going
to be the first step for America and the
Department of Justice and the FBI to
begin the healing process the healing
process would be made much easier if we
could complete that by them delivering
all the documents to us tomorrow they're
supposed to deliver documents to the
speaker and myself we inform every
Republican member on our committee
signed a letter today to the Department
of Justice to say it is totally
unacceptable
an investigation that we started up it
the only way we're all Tamila gonna stop
there's two ways there's two ways one we
can hold mr. Rosen Stein and others in
the Department of Justice and contempt
and impeach the other way would be for
the President of the United States to to
demand them to to order them to give us
all the documents those are really the
only two ways that because it needs to
hear this message the president needs to
hear this message but what are you
willing to go sir as far as impeaching
well I'm already past that look I
already wanted to move to content months
ago the Speaker of the House believes
that he can work with DOJ and and we're
going to continue to try to work that
path tomorrow but I can tell you that my
patience has run out I have none left
and now it's really up to the leadership
of the house and the president the
United States in order to make sure that
our subpoena gets complied with well
we cannot have a Deputy Attorney General
of the United States that is preventing
Congress from doing their constitutional
job and threatening people using the
power of that office which is so
powerful to intimidate harass and and
basically stifle the job your your
Constitution requires you to do mr.
chairman thank you